your doctor will give you an epidural
steroid injection to reduce inflammation
in your spine reducing pain and allowing
time for your condition to heal the
spine consists of bony vertebrae stacked
one on the other shock-absorbing
intervertebral discs lying between the
vertebrae ligaments and muscles
connecting the bones and the spinal cord
with it's branching spinal nerves
the spinal cord is bathed in
cerebrospinal fluid and surrounded by a
protective membrane called the dura just
outside this membrane is the epidural
space each intervertebral disc consists
of a tough outer layer called the
annulus fibrosus and a spongy inner
material called the nucleus pulposus
from aging or injury the annulus
fibrosus may weaken or degenerate as a
result the disc may bulge into the
surrounding neural and vascular
structures causing inflammation and pain
if the annulus completely breaks down
the nucleus may lose through causing a
disc herniation the resulting
inflammation and swelling may irritate
one of the spinal nerves nearby
resulting in a condition known as
radiculopathy disc herniation in the
lower or lumbar region of the back tend
to produce shooting pain down the leg a
condition known as sciatica if a disc
herniates in the neck the pain radiates
into the arm
another condition that can cause pain
and inflammation in the area of the
spinal nerves is osteoarthritis which
may cause excess bone growth at the
joints of the spine resulting in
compression of the nearby spinal nerves
and epidural steroid injection is a
minimally invasive procedure to begin
your doctor will numb the skin on your
back with a local anaesthetic
using an x-ray image for guidance your
doctor will insert a needle between the
bones and through the ligaments of your
spine until it reaches the epidural
space at the level of the inflammation
once the needle has been inserted into
the epidural space your doctor will
inject a steroid solution
after your procedure you may apply ice
to the injection area for pain relief
and take over-the-counter pain
medications you may be able to resume
driving after 24 hours